[Music]
all right
how many of you guys listen to kpop
that's a no for me sir that's a no for
you i'm big fans of blackpink
blackpink really good job that's a k-pop
group i listen to amber lou
oh same i don't even know if we can say
that anymore video
can you say that still oh i don't know i
don't know look at me now look at you
is that a reference to the song oh okay
yeah we this group does not strike me as
a k-pop
group i just said i like black pink
oh right right i like their music i just
sang their lyrics
i just said i was in an ambulance i'm
not if we're allowed to say that
we're not allowed to say that though i
watch um their music videos only at
korean barbecue or you actually
go out and write a search like no
sometimes some people send it to me and
i watch it
but there's no replay value for me that
makes sense that makes sense and i think
it's because for music
i like i guess i like to listen to the
lyrics and understand no
i don't i listen to i listen to traveler
music i played a lot of dance dance
revolution
in high school does that count is there
k-pop in there it's like all k-pop
dude dance dance revolution if they
haven't done it they definitely should
have a k-pop version remixes or whatever
wow i know it's not k-pop but gangnam
style got stuck in my head for about two
years
isn't that k-pop that's k-pop is it yeah
i think so yeah
it came from korea if you say so that's
korean i just when i picture kpop i'm
thinking about young people dancing
around
yeah saying like in a group not an older
guy that's why he's like a rebel he
stood out oh
because he was like a regular just dude
just singing and dancing but anyways
k-pop has taken the world by storm if
you guys didn't know you guys are living
in a rock
but a man in the uk by the name of
oliver frost aka
ali london this is handle on instagram
uh he has spent 150
000 in plastic surgery in order to look
like
jimin from uh the bts oh i know bts and
me too i've heard of bts i like bts
well k-pop is huge right like like
they've been the top
i don't know like half of like the top
most viewed videos on youtube are kpop
very true
ooh i like his hair all right so this is
this is jimendo so this is the
the k-pop star and this is oliver who is
trying to look i think we could have
figured that out isn't he trying to look
like him too though
yeah maybe he's trying to look like he
has blue contact's on right yeah he's
trying he's trying to airy in it up it a
little he's looking like him and he's
looking like him
personal opinion i feel like he looks
more like john and kate plus eight
he looks like ellen that's cool too
right that's really cool
yeah it's great it kind of just looks
like bart baker a little bit
a little bit he's actually a k-pop star
now or like a c-pop star yeah
he looks more like barbara on a shark
tank oh
yeah you nailed it that is really good
he looks like he was trying to look like
barbara from shark tank he would have
he did it you're so right that should be
his default
like so who cares about it look like
k-pop is who i was really trying to look
like i like that barber she had a heart
of gold that barbie yeah are you guys
ready to see
she likes young strong men yes she does
yeah she does she always invests in them
really so you just you just have to look
good and be strong-looking sometimes i
think she just spent 150 grand on a hug
yep she's uh i really do quite the sugar
mama before and after of oliver
bam he has done a lot of work in the
video there's a video that accompanied
his article and he was saying how he
when he looks at this particular picture
which is right before he did the
surgeries
and it's like years of surgeries right
he says he does not relate to this
person
anymore of course he remembers like the
day he took the photo but he does not
feel like that's him anymore yeah i
wouldn't want to be him either
oh [ __ ] they look like two different
people yeah they do
everybody looks at that dude like oh
that guy's so busted dude
that's a busted guy right yeah and then
he's like look at me i'm pretty
dang i don't think he looks that bad
completely but [ __ ] busted nikki
jesus i'm speaking i'm speaking on
behalf of oliver
oh okay i got his back dude true true
i mean that's tight for him to like have
an idea and then go after it i think
that's [ __ ] cool
i think it's um borderline obsessive but
hey if he's [ __ ] happy
you can't say that geo say what that is
he's borderline obsessive this is a
beautiful thing no matter what
percent beautiful you say obsessive i
say committed
some people thank you you just called
him ugly as [ __ ]
his past his past he likes to knew him
only because he was stuck in his box
yeah and and jio's saying oh he was
looked okay in there and we're saying
that's not okay
some people they think they're lizards
and then they'll go tattooing and then
they'll poo all these things they'll be
like
and then they'll go around detroit
acting like a lizard they split their
tongues yep that's there's a lizard
that's pretty hot
that's just weird uh-huh i want to be
able to be able to do that and
just for a day i don't want it to be
permanent but to be able to do this your
tongue yeah that's pretty sick i want
steve to be able to do that
during certain which one activity
you care to explain like when we're
riding bikes
i'll get better at it i'll get better at
it i swear
it's the last thing i do thank you
yeah so here oliver he's uh analyzed his
own face from before
and analyzed jimin's face and he's
really wanting almond eye shape so his
next surgery is to try and
get his eyes isn't that crazy and is any
friend gonna
slant his eyes a little bit that's
friend hey buddy
what are you doing this for do you want
to go to therapy at all no in the video
that
accompanied this article he had friends
come over and he was explaining to
them like hey these are my next surgery
you know operations i want to do
what do you think and all his friends
were just kind of speechless and like uh
you know what i think you had to have an
intervention because they're like
you want chinese eyes what's wrong with
you right
right and he's he's like he doesn't
necessarily want to change his race and
he's like very adamant about that he's
like i'm not trying to change my room no
no no no no no i love being one trying
to look exactly like korean don't get me
wrong i'm not giving up my white card
here
he's like wait wait i don't i don't want
i don't want that to be taken away i
just want the eyes like asian
exactly that's like the main thing
though that is the main thing he hasn't
done it yet but what he has done though
over the years is he's been trying to
inject more fat
into his that is so [ __ ] funny the
plastic surgery guy was like saying
you know asians typically just have we
have more fat in our uh
face right so it's not so bony and
angular looking it's a lot you know just
that's so racist
flat looking oh i mean it's coming from
a plastic i think it's wrong
you think it's wrong to say that asians
have more fat in their faces yes i do i
think that's wrong
well i i yeah sitting on the mount
looking down and saying that's racist i
think i got mochi cheeks
plastic surgery in itself is just a
racist thing
yeah sure i i i well okay so a bunch of
beauty gurus were getting in trouble for
that fox side trend
what's that because it's mimicking
almond eyes or whatever yeah and
well the way they were posing was like
this so they were like why were they
posing like that like this
they want their eyes to look more asian
and then there's a
there's a surgery that um celebrities
have been getting called
i watched this whole video that this
girl broke down why she did wasn't
comfortable about it
but um there's like this surgery that
makes your eyes go like this
uh that i think gigi hadid had got or
something
um but it's called an oriental facelift
oriental yes and it's specifically to
make your eyes more almond
isn't it crazy how things keep changing
like when we were kids like you get made
fun of for these eyes
exactly and now everyone's like oh it's
so exotic i want it that's what she was
having a problem with like she's like
it's not really that they're doing it
it's that like
we used to get really made fun of
foreign i'm all for it
if they want to start being like me take
it [ __ ] if you think this is harder and
you want to suck my dick bar
let's do it yeah let's [ __ ] do it it
is crazy though because like there's a
trend where a lot of asians were getting
like the eyelid surgery to look more
western
they were opening up their eyes and
doing the fold man yeah but now
it's western is trying to get more asian
do you think we're gonna just all look
alike eventually i hope not
in asia like i think it's still really
prevalent to get the double eyelid fold
surgery right and then obviously
k-pop stars are all getting their faces
done in a way that has that k-pop
look because even like koreans like most
don't look like k-pop stars but a lot of
people are getting
going under the knife to look more like
that's true because we were in korea
and i was looking for k-pop stars and i
just saw them on the billboard i didn't
see them in the streets
the regular people don't look the same
dude it was inevitable this is always
going to happen there's billions of
asians
yeah we never had a shot oh sure
everyone's going to look more asian yeah
in the future if everyone just
mixed that'll be the norm i don't know
though cause like i felt like i feel
like the rounder eyes were the dominant
genes in my case like in every mixed
race
i don't like asian at all it's like a
two he doesn't yeah well he
looks a little
everyone's going to look middle eastern
and latin
because even hawaiians like they're
super mixed out there
like not whole native hawaii but like
people in hawaii who are like mixed with
portuguese asian whatevers
they all look pretty latino or middle
eastern well you know
the spaniards did conquer a lot of
countries too so we don't even know how
much was mixed pre
then mixing you know there was only one
group
and it was called the colonials and they
are the ones who colonized everything
why your eyes get expensive nobody else
colonizes anything nikki i'll have you
know spanish people
um they're mixed with middle eastern too
everybody's just a mixture
we've been mixing for centuries and i
would like to
say that there is one group of people
that colonized others that weren't white
and it was um uh embarrassingly
the japanese true they were trying to
take over asia the spaniards and the
japanese that's very interesting i don't
know
what what what about genghis khan was he
trying to colonize or just like
village he just said hey dog you want
people to die
in your place and they're like nah
they're like all right you pay taxes
and then they go and then they come up
to the next one and they'll be like hey
you guys want people to die in your
village and they're like nah [ __ ] you
you can't come in here
okay i kill you and then yeah what's the
difference between colonizing someone
and then conquering someone is there a
difference i feel like it's the same
in terms of what we're talking about our
subject matter which is the mixing of
races
i think it's the same [ __ ] well the
colonizing part is like they try to
be like no this is a good thing like we
look we're so like
we're giving you civilization i think
one is like
hey it's good that i rape you it's good
that i rape you but i think
conquering is just i'm gonna rape you
yeah conquering is straight up
this is my place now so the babies that
come out
they're still mixed it's just under
different explanations gentrification
looks like colonization and please can
it happen to my neighbor's house like
[ __ ] sake
i want my property value to go up not
down and not sideways
even green oh [ __ ]
but yeah so oliver here is uh seven
years into
trying to make himself look like a k-pop
star and uh he's still going at it i
feel like there was a dude that was
similar
in brazil that tried to look like a ken
doll yeah
yeah man and they both came out kind of
looking the same yeah
he actually kind of looks like michael
jackson a little bit because i think
it's his obsession with his
rounder nose over here and then if you
look here it's just it's got that
michael jackson point now which i'm like
you're not really nailing the korean
look with the pointy nose i don't know
if koreans are known for pointy noses
but
sure it must suck not being able to be
who you want to be
[Laughter]
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you